hey guys it's Tuesday January fifth I'm
Mary and you're watching gamespot news
from our new offices in downtown San
Francisco fancy first up is a follow-up
story to yesterday's news about PSM
being down its back up the furthermore
Sonia is saying that they're going to
lengthen the PS Plus and PS mail
subscription services to compensate
anyone who's been affected writing on
the official PlayStation Twitter account
Sony thanked users for their patience
while they worked to restore the network
it added the players should stay tuned
for details on PS Plus PS now and video
rental extensions it's not clear how
long Sony will extend user subscriptions
for for reference after the major xmas
2014 outage which dragged on for almost
a week Sony offered five day extension
for the PlayStation related
subscriptions this time PSN was only
down for about 10 hours so we're not
really sure how they're gonna make this
one right a bunch of game hating Weiner
Lisey bags calling themselves the
Phantom squad has claimed responsibility
for knocking the PSN services offline
thus admitting that phantom squad stands
for petty half-assed nobody's that obey
mother next up if you don't have an xbox
one you're probably interested to know
when you're gonna be able to play rise
of the Tomb Raider good news it's really
soon if you want played on pc rise of
the Tomb Raider will launch for PC on
january twenty eighth square enix and
Crystal Dynamics announced today the
action-adventure game debuted in
November 2015 as a timed exclusive for
xbox one and 360 the pc edition of rise
of the Tomb Raider was developed at
Crystal Dynamics in nixa software it
will support 4k resolution to offer
stunning new detail rides the tomb
raider will be available through
physical retailers and online
marketplaces such as steam windows store
and square enix's own store the standard
edition will be 60 bucks while the
digital deluxe edition featuring the
game and it's DLC path will sell for 90
rise the tomb raider is also coming to
ps4 but not until holiday of 2016 oculus
VR made some friends today announced
that anyone who bought a development kit
in the original Kickstarter is getting a
free rift that's right if you pledge it
enough for a rift development kit which
pledges start around 275 bucks you get a
free kick starter edition oculus rift
all you got to do is fill out a survey
from Kickstarter before februari first
and provide a shipping address you'll
need to live in one of the 20 countries
that oculus rift launches in though they
weren't specified oculus says it's
working on an alternative for people who
don't live in those countries the oculus
team said you were at the beginning of
our journey we couldn't have done it
without you oculus rift Kickstarter
campaign started in August 2012 and blew
past its 250 thousand dollar funding
target in under a day in March of 2014
that social networking giant that your
parents always use acquired oculus VR 42
billion oculus rift pre-orders will open
tomorrow january six at which time we're
likely to learn at least a price and
possibly the release date will have all
that news as it's announced well that's
it for me today but I'll be back again
tomorrow with more news the event